forma eu fui montando essa palestra eu
gostaria até de fazer essa brincadeira
com vocês toda vez que alguém me
perguntava o que tem na gaveta da sua
mente eu devolvi a pergunta o que tem na
sua essa angústia do vazio de você não
sabia direito o que tem na sua mente
nesse momento foi todo o meu processo
criativo para montar essa palestra é
mais ou menos o que acontece com cada um
de vocês
o tempo todo quando eu preciso ter uma
idéia quando eu preciso solucionar um
problema nós temos essa angústia
existencial
então eu queria convidar vocês a fazer
um exercício
imaginem uma gaveta de qualquer jeito
de qualquer forma imaginaram
agora tem tem descrever como ela é
entre em contato com ela o que tem
dentro ela está vazia ela tenha objetos
ela tem documentos ela tem fotos ela tem
sentimentos
depois a gente a profunda mais um
pouquinho
como é o seu sentimento ao abrir essa
gaveta
o que você sente ao entrar em contato
com cada coisa que tá ali dentro
será que essa gaveta é a sua vida eu
digo mais essa gaveta é você ao descrevê
lá nós estamos nos descrevendo a olhar
para o que tem dentro dela
nós estamos entrando em contato com quem
a gente é
então eu gostaria de pensar em uma outra
questão
nós existimos temos essa certeza estamos
aqui qualquer diferença de existir e de
ter essência na vida
o tapete existe você existe eu existo
o telão existe uma planta existe a
essência é o que a gente coloca como
intenção como consciência
o tapete a meu ver pode ser vermelho
talvez um daltônico discorde o tapete
ele pode ser macio
ele pode ser pequeno o palco também
existe para alguns
dá medo pavor pra outros nossa adoro
essência é o que a gente dá como valor
para as coisas
ou seja a gente está na vida nós vivemos
nós temos a nossa existência
passamos por algumas situações às vezes
a gente dá a essência aquilo como algo
bom ou ruim
e aí eu gostaria de provocar mais um
pouquinho
será que a gente precisa dar esse valor
de ou bom ou ruim
será que as coisas não são boas e ruins
tudo tem dois lados milhões de lados
depende da perspectiva depende de quem
está dando valor e essência para aquilo
quando a gente pensa em polaridades né
é bom ou ruim bem e mal alto baixo
nós temos a tendência há sempre ficar
nas extremidades e isso nem sempre nos
causa algo bom não é saúde
quando a gente fala em saúde mental
ficar nas extremidades
é o que causa sofrimento é o que causa
conflito interno
o ideal seria a gente entender que se a
gente está de um lado da balança a gente
é totalmente rígido
a gente precisa trabalhar nossa
flexibilidade que é o outro lado da
balança
talvez a gente erra a mão no primeiro
momento né gente fica flexível demais
mas porque quando a gente coloca peso do
outro lado da balança ela vai tender a
fazer um movimento de se ajustar e aí
ela vai começar a entrar num equilíbrio
a gente pode entender isso no nosso
próprio corpo
quando a gente gere um alimento que é
ácido nosso corpo vai fabricar a
substância básica porque precisa
neutralizar tudo na natureza tem um
equilíbrio nós fazemos parte dessa
natureza nós somos natureza
então nós também temos que buscar esse
equilíbrio
muitas vezes a gente se enrijecem uma
crença e não se permite trabalhar lá
buscando a flexibilidade a criatividade
como usar ela de uma maneira mais
criativa e flexível conseguindo usar
essa habilidade é essa competência de
uma maneira a se ajustar se adequar no
ambiente
então nós não somos só coisas boas
e também não somos só coisas ruins
nossas experiências não são só as
experiências boas mas também não são
experiências ruins
agora a pergunta que é mais difícil de
ser respondida né como colocaram uma
experiência ruim convertê la numa
experiência boa
será que a gente precisa fazer sem preço
o que eu percebo hoje na atualidade é um
excesso de otimismo e todo excesso não
faz bem é uma extremidade
mas aí o otimismo é importante a gente
não pode descartar podemos ser otimistas
lidando também com o que é pessimista se
preparando para o pior
olhando para as nossas fragilidades para
as nossas dificuldades nos cuidando
todos temos dificuldades todos estão
todos temos uma dificuldade de motivar
se em algum aspecto
ninguém é totalmente desmotivado
todo mundo tem motivação para alguma
coisa seja para tomar água conta com
sede
todo mundo tem uma necessidade e essa
necessidade ela sempre tem que ser
satisfeita quando essas cidades ficam
esquecidas na gaveta porque é difícil da
conta eu não quero entrar em contato
aquilo vai machucar
aí fica mais difícil de você conseguir
completar aquela necessidade e por que
que às vezes a gente está na nossa vida
de repente a gente lembra de um trauma
que a gente teve lá no passado a nossa
mente ela só trabalha com o passado
presente ficado então esse presente esse
momento agora tudo o que vem na cabeça
de vocês quando eu perguntei o que há na
gaveta da sua mente se tornou presente
são perguntas a serem respondidas são
situações a serem cuidadas precisam de
atenção e quando a gente cuida quando a
gente conhece e entrou em contato com
quem a gente é a gente está buscando
nosso desenvolvimento ea vida faz mais
sentido
nesse sentido
quando a gente entra em contato para
aquilo que está doendo com gentileza
percebe se respeita não vou dar conta
não quero dar conta disso ou não eu vou
enfrentar ísso é uma coisa que eu quero
e preciso melhorar
você vai atrás das ferramentas porque
você fez a escolha você vai atrás das
ferramentas e de repente você descobre
algo novo
você recomeça outro aprendizado você
reverte aquela crença que estava tão
rígida de um lado da balança e começa a
permitir-se esse trabalhando quando a
gente entra em contato com a gente é
algo muito poderoso
eu escutava na minha infância né e acho
que vocês também que o conhecimento
ninguém tira então o que que isso causou
todo mundo estudo estudo estudo de tudo
pra que ao longo dos anos de terapia que
eu venho também fazendo como psicóloga
também é eu descobri que
autoconhecimento nos dá muito mais poder
justamente para utilizar o próprio
conhecimento que a gente vai adquirindo
ao longo da vida aí sim faz sentido
estudar estudar e estudar estudar
além disso não faz sentido só gente
existir sentir ter ressentimentos
guardados na gaveta ter medos e crenças
guardados na gaveta
se eu não posso atualizar a gente tá
aqui na vida ainda tem um conceito que
se chama y idade que em faz ficar em
movimento é eu em mudança o tempo todo
essa é a vida a gente tem oportunidade
todos os dias e se atualizar de entrar
em contato com quem a gente é e de poder
ressignificar tudo que há de difícil e
dolorido no que a gente viveu então eu
pergunto pra vocês o que há na gaveta da
sua mente o que essa gaveta diz de você
o que você quer
hoje com tudo o que você já viveu e no
momento presente que você está aqui
agora quer dizer pressa gaveta
o que você tem vontade de falar para ela
para montar essa palestra eu abri a
gaveta pra falar que com vocês eu estou
abrindo a gaveta e vem muita coisa na
cabeça
a gente se prepara as vezes nos três
horas pra falar 15 minutos
tem conteúdo para umas três horas
a nossa gaveta o tempo todo em movimento
o tempo todo tem coisas que ficam no
fundo tem coisas que eu coloco pra
frente tem coisa que eu coloco embaixo
tem coisa que eu deixo bem prático para
onde olhar e pegar a nossa gaveta é uma
riqueza e como ela está em movimento
a gente pode utilizar a criatividade
para lidar com ela
criar situações para aprender com ela
para aprender com esses conteúdos da
nossa vida
então o que eu deixo para vocês hoje que
fica de mais forte em mim nesse momento
agora na minha gaveta e que salta é se
conheçam
é muito importante se cuidem pratiquem o
auto-cuidado busquem se auto desenvolver
só você pode fazer isso muitas vezes não
está fora cá dentro
a motivação ela não tá fora a gente fica
buscando buscando buscando mas não ela
está dentro você precisa encontrar um
motivo pra agir
então o que há na gaveta da sua mente o
que falta para você criar com essa
gaveta com que você tenha na sua gaveta
talvez coragem talvez motivação auto
desenvolvimento é algo que a gente tem
que fazer durante nossa vida
então se conheçam se cuidem e se
desenvolvam
obrigado
[Aplausos]